science stop science en collaboration
avec l'université du bonheur minet
street science et magie en terre du
milieu vous présente aujourd'hui
l'histoire naturelle de la terre du
milieu
oh mais on les entend d'ici les rabat
joie on s'en fiche c'est qu'un film et
magnani et gnagnagna mais figurez-vous
que non le seigneur des anneaux ce n'est
pas qu'un film ce sont six films ainsi
que tout un univers étendu qui a été
développé au travers d'une pelleté deux
bouquins qui ont inspiré auteur ministre
à helle troubadours poètes et autres
artistes de tous pinceaux et de tout
poil alors pourquoi pas des
scientifiques 1 comme le dit mon docteur
la science c'est cool alors commençons
par situer la terre du milieu dans
l'univers la terre du milieu possède à
soleil des jours et des nuits et et
connaît des cycles lunaires en tout
point identique au nôtre ce qui nous
montre card à la planète qui porte la
terre du milieu et ronde tourne sur
elle-même et autour d'un soleil et
possède un satellite naturel similaire à
notre lune en fait tarder à est la copie
conforme de notre terre et les
simplement situé dans une réalité disons
alternative
oui enfin on notera quand même que les
masses continentales darda sont assez
différentes de celles de notre terre ils
y allaient terre immortel ou valley nord
à l'ouest et la terre du milieu à l'est
c'est quand même pas exactement comme
chez nous oui et c'est la montre car dal
a connu une histoire géologique qui lui
est propre
pour commencer regardons la carte
détaillée de la terre du milieu le mieux
connue de ces deux continents
on y voit apparaître de nombreuses
chaînes de montagnes qui sont autant de
cicatrices une histoire géologique
mouvementée et oui une montagne ne se
situe jamais là par hasard
elle est généralement le fruit de la
collision entre deux plaques tectoniques
qui cheminait dans des directions
opposées
c'est ainsi qu'en terre du milieu on
peut voir des montagnes relativement
ancienne base et au sommet érodé par le
temps et des montagnes plus hautes
car plus récentes les plus anciennes
montagnes de la terre du milieu sur les
montagnes bleues à l'ouest de la comté
on sait que ces montagnes sont les plus
anciennes car elles ont eu le temps de
se former puis de s'effondrer sous leur
propre poids et d'être rodés au fil du
temps un peu à l'image du massif central
et des vosges en france en effet le
massif central et les vosges et même une
bonne partie de la bretagne forme est
entre 350 et 250 millions d'années une
immense chaîne de montagne qu'on appelle
la chaîne hercynienne cette chaîne de
montagne est née suite à la collision
de messe continentale le laurentien au
nord et le gondwana au sud il ya 350
millions d'années
c'est d'ailleurs à cette époque que se
forme la pangée le continent unique qui
a vu la naissance des dinosaures ainsi
si montaigne basse gironde qui forment
le massif central le massif armoricain
et les vosges sont en quelque sorte les
cicatrices presque résorbés de cet
antique chez de montagneuse hercynienne
et avant cette époque le territoire
français étaient divisés partagé entre
le gondwana et le laurentia pour la
terre du milieu c'est pareil les
montagnes bleues représente la dernière
partie émergée d'une ancienne chaîne de
montagnes en partie effondré et
aujourd'hui englouti sous les eaux elle
est le témoignage de la collision qui a
eu lieu autrefois entre la plaque
tectonique du vally nord et celle de
leiria d'or et oui à l'époque la grande
mère n'existait pas terre du milieu est
valide arrêté sous des efforts mais la
ponzi dada vieille comme la chaîne
hercynienne d'au moins 300 millions
d'années
et voici apparaître la chaîne de
montagnes qui forment la cicatrice de la
collision entre valley nord et ria d'or
l'équivalent de la chaîne hercynienne
sur la peau rejette darda plusieurs
millions d'années plus tard peut être
une centaine la plongée darda a commencé
à se disloquer comme la nôtre les
mouvements de convection du manteau
terrestre ont créé une dorsale océanique
entre valley nord et ryad or qui a
encore des millions d'années plus tard
finit par c'est pareil de nouveau les
deux masses continentales latence
activité volcanique au niveau de cette
dorsale océanique et l'accumulation de
coulées de lave ou même conduit à
l'apparition d'une île volcanique numé
nord qui est un peu à la grand'mère
darda ce que l'islande est à
l'atlantique
évidemment la lente dérive vers l'est du
continent portant la terre du milieu ne
s'est pas faite sans heurts et l'attaqué
ryder a rapidement fini par rencontrer
d'autres plaques tectoniques sur son
passage avec laquelle elle est entrée en
collision formant de nouvelles montagnes
il ya d'abord eu la collision avec la
plaque romagon et le vieux kraton
granitique du rohan portant l'actuelle
mise en garde le royaume du rohan et le
royaume n'adhérer bord
mais attention ces derniers n'existait
pas encore eu n'apparaîtront que des
millions d'années plus tard cette
collision d'une rare intensité a donné
naissance aux montagnes ou grises aux
membres
et à la moria dont les failles profondes
des thèmes man x réactiver ce qui a
permis la formation et la précipitation
amphi nom d'anne alliage naturel de
platine et de palladium
formé à très haute pression et très
haute température
le précieux mithril l'ensemble remanié
en plus c'est ryanair va ensuite
rencontré la plaque du gondor formant
ainsi une grande chaîne de montagnes
dont l'effondrement partiel donnera
naissance à la baie de belles fallas ne
laissant sur pied que les montagnes
blanches
ce sont ces dernières qui porteront plus
tard les futurs feux de détresse du
gondor l'histoire des montagnes blanches
ressemble à celle des pires années comme
elle les pyrénées sont à la fois
relativement ancienne est encore très
haute
elles ont donc dit comme les pyrénées
site à la rotation de la plaque ibérique
contre le site de la plaque eurasiatique
se former il ya entre 100 et 50 millions
d'années la chaîne de montagnes qui
résultat de ce mouvement de plaques
s'appelle la chaîne pyrénées au
provençal
elle s'est aujourd'hui complètement
effondré entraînant dans sa chute la
formation du golfe du lion s'est dit
boucler la corse et la sardaigne était
autrefois rattachée à la france
eh bien c'est ce même effondrement qui
entre 30 et 10 millions d'années des
tâches à la corse et la sardaigne et du
continent finalement ce qu'il reste de
la chaîne des pyrénées n'est que la
partie émergée de cette très ancienne
chaîne pyrénées au provençal
le dernier événement tectoniques et pas
des moindres de l'histoire de la terre
du milieu et la collision de cette
dernière avec une toute petite plaque
venu là poinçonnet par l'est je veux
bien sûr parler du mordant
non mais la musique c'était pas la peine
sort on était même pas n'est d'ailleurs
même son espèce n'était pas encore né
l'arrivée de la plaque du mordor a
bouleversé la géologie de la terre du
milieu
premièrement les jeunes montagne à la
fois haute et escarpées qui entourent la
plaque du mordor forme d'un bastion
naturel qui explique que dans ce cas
comme dans bien d'autres les frontières
politiques recouvre les frontières
géologiques naturels
c'est exactement comme pour l'italie la
plaque portant l'italie qu'on appelle
plaque a pu lienne a percuté et percute
encore l'eurasie et la chaîne de
montagnes résultante les alpes forme une
barrière naturelle infranchissable dont
les italiens ont stratégiquement ont
fait leurs frontières
on retrouve d'ailleurs la même logique
stratégique au niveau des pyrénées entre
l'espagne et la france
deuxièmement le caractère très intrusif
de la collision avec la plaque du mans
d'armes à faire rejouer de nombreuses
failles anciennes elle va d'abord
réhausser les anciennes montagne en
particulier les montagnes blanches mais
surtout elle va faire rejouer les dièye
faye associé à la collision de leiria
d'or du rova nyon et du gondor côté est
alors que les forces à hisser jusque là
en compression elles vont s'inverser et
fait réagir les failles en l'extension
est un grand rift va se former c'est à
dire une zone où les plaques
continentales ses cartes et où la croûte
s'amincit cette zone d'effondrement le
rift en duo va livrer passage au long
fleuve du même nom exactement comme en
france où les rifts alsatia de limagne
et du sillon rhodanien vont livrer
passage à deux grands fleuves tel que le
rat ou le rhône season des rifts
français ne se sont plaints formé suite
à l'arrivée du mordor bien sûr mais
suite à la sionisation les alpes il ya
20 millions d'années qui en fait rejouer
les traits vieillis faille située le
long de l'ancienne chaîne hercynienne
selon cet axe nord-sud ses rives sont
des reliefs négatif et par conséquent il
s'agit de zones privilégiées pour
l'accumulation de calcaire et d'autres
sédiments formant des pierres qui seront
très prisé par les hommes pour la
construction de forteresse par exemple à
partir de maintenant nous entrons dans
ce que l'on pourrait appeler l'histoire
de la terre du milieu qui se
distinguerait de sa préhistoire par le
fait que les événements
le gic que nous relaterons désormais au
mont fait l'objet d'une description plus
ou moins d'un ennemi théologie dans le
grand livre des légendes garda le
silmarillion commençons par le
volcanisme faire des failles et des
trous partout dans la croûte terrestre
pendant des millions d'années n'est
jamais sans conséquence
sûrement pas et toutes les failles qui
sont apparus à l'occasion des collisions
des continents les uns avec les autres
vont être autant de zones de faiblesse
qui vont permettre la remontée du magma
en fusion depuis le manteau jusqu'à la
surface comme du café non d'un sucre
s'est par ailleurs exactement ce qui
s'est produit dans le massif central
pensiez vous que les volcans s'y
trouvait justement par hasard mais non
c'est bien parce qu'ici se trouvait déjà
un grand nombre de failles que le magma
ci est faux filet et a formé les fameux
volcan d'auvergne le massif central est
parcouru de volcans de tous âges mais
les plus récents comme ceux de la chaîne
des puys ont moins de quarante mille ans
et ne sont techniquement tate alors ses
volcans de la terre darda où sont ils
il y a bien sûr aux ruines la montagne
du destin l'unique volcans actifs connus
en terre du milieu et dont les cendres
et les lave noire recouvre complètement
le mordor il ya ensuite les hangars de
mardi sorcier saint romain dont la terre
noire et la forme on cratère trahissent
la nature volcanique
il s'agit certainement d'un ancien
cratère d'explosion qu'on appelle une
caldeira mais ce volcan n'est pas
inactif pour autant puisque ça oman
utilise la chaleur dégagée par la lave
pour alimenter ses forges
il ya aussi des points d'activité
volcanique plus intense mais moins connu
d'abord la chaîne de tango dream des
volcans dont les lave se sont injectés à
travers les failles de l'ancienne chaîne
des montagnes bleues ses volcans
extrêmement actif protéger la demeure du
légendaire maître de son celui qui lui a
tout appris du mal melkor et enfin il y
à l'île volcanique de nu mais nord dont
nous avons déjà parlé et qui connaît un
regain d'activité important puisqu'il va
conduire ni plus ni moins qu'à la
destruction totale de l'île à la fin du
premier âge il ya 6000 ans environ de
même les volcans du tango dream bien qui
fusent if vont exploser
un phénomène rare qui survient lorsque
la masse de l'avs rencontre une nappe
d'eau souterraine
le cratère gigantesque résultant est
appelé marc l'explosion de ce marc va
engloutir toutes les régions
environnantes en particulier le bel
erian landes bande à la fin du premier
âge
une fois de plus il ya à peu près six
mille ans cet événement fut si
catastrophique
que la légende s'en souvient encore en
l'associant à la mort du dragon mythique
en cas lagon le noir l'un petit sont à
peu près synchrone du num hainard de
langogne et du bellay riante pourrait
aussi être en partie due à la fin d'une
période glaciaire de courte durée on
sait en effet qu'avant la fin du premier
âge un glacier recouvrait la région d'el
carax qui permettait de passer à pied
sec entre la terre du milieu et les
terres immortel à l'image de la béringie
qui dans notre monde à nous permettait
durant la dernière ère glaciaire de
passer à pied sec entre l'asie et
l'amérique
la fonte du glacier d'elle carax et loki
l'art largué dans les océans 1
certainement contribué à
l'engloutissement du num hainard et du
blé à riom en bande en plus de
l'activité volcanique
il est à noter que la disparition du
pont naturel entre la terre du milieu et
les terres immortal est relatée dans la
légende comme l'époque où la terre c'est
ça d'être plate
sous-entendu unis pour devenir ronde
jolie métaphore n'est ce pas mais
finalement qu'est devenu le climat de la
terre du milieu après tous ces
bouleversements géologiques et
climatiques
et bien croyez le ou non mais la réponse
nous vient d'une simulation sur
ordinateur dont les résultats ont été
publiés en ligne et qui est signée de
radagast le bras lui même si vous le
souhaitez un lien pour télécharger la
publication est accessible dans la
description de la vidéo
cette simulation où ce modèle climatique
si vous préférez montre que le climat de
la terre du milieu n'est pas si
différent de celui de notre terre il
compte en effet une zone tempérée une
zone polaire aux narines zones arides à
l'équateur comme sur terre la zone
tempérée où se trouve la luxuriante
comté et la pénétrable forêt sombre
possède un climat très semblable à celui
de la france et est recouverte par une
végétation qui lui est très comparable
lunel de radagast et nous apprend même
que les précipitations venant de l'ouest
sont bloqués au dessus de la comté paris
mon brumeux et donc que les plaines à
l'est de ces montagnes connaissent un
défaut de précipitations par rapport à
celles situées à l'ouest la fertilité
des terres de l'ouest du à ce surplus
d'arrosage expliquerait pourquoi
l'agriculture s'est solidement établi à
l'ouest des monts brumeux en territoire
au but notamment alors que les
territoires de l'est peuple et dance et
de créatures maléfiques sont restés
couverts de forêts sauvages
l'influencent de l'homme est extrêmement
palpable dans le paysage de la terre du
milieu notamment
de la déforestation due à l'extension de
l'agriculture en effet s'il n'y avait
pas eu l'agriculture le modèle de
radagast prévoit que la terre du milieu
aurait été majoritairement recouverte de
forêts forêt qui aurait été d'autant
plus dense que la concentration de
l'atmosphère en dioxyde de carbone gaz
dont les plantes ont besoin pour grandir
et quatre fois supérieure à celle de
notre planète
autant dire que dans des conditions
pareilles les grandes plaines ou galope
les fiers cavaliers du roi aurait été
impraticable de façon très intéressante
il est remarquable de noter que d'après
ce modèle le mordor aurait été une terre
relativement aride et hostile
même en l'absence de son sinistre m
seront ici il n'y avait pas eu les
cendres de la montagne du destin pour
tout recouvrir il est même certain que
le mordor aurait joui d'une végétation
ténu mais bien présentes semblable à une
steppe tel qu'il en existe dans le
godard la répartition des vents
dominants toujours d'après radagast est
quant à elle assez sable au sud les
vents soufflent majoritairement d'ouest
en est
tandis qu'au nord c'est le contraire les
vents soufflent et emporte les navires
vers l'ouest ce qui explique pourquoi
les elfes ont fondé les abris le port
dont partait navire en partance pour les
déraillements tel au nord de la terre du
milieu
terminant maintenant avec la
biodiversité de la terre du milieu qui
pour ne rien vous cacher est quasiment
identique à celle que nous connaissons
il y à des végétaux bien sûr dont nous
venons de parler des invertébrés et des
vertébrés comme des poissons faut bien
les groupes
des reptiles et des oiseaux et bien sûr
des mammifères et des hominidés
bref tout un joli baissière qui ne se
distingue d'une autre que par quel plus
d'innovation évolutive inédite chez nous
une certaine tendance au gigantisme
gigantisme qui n'est toutefois pas sans
complètement évoqué certaines espèces
fossiles qui ont existé dans notre monde
autrefois ce sont de la partie - sgs mal
quitte je suis tout pour voir les
éléments les plus étranges et 7 phone
sont d'ailleurs les créatures à la fois
gigantesque et ailés qui ne se rend
compte que dans le pire milieu qui sont
pour elle des cavernes ou être grand et
savoir voler ne sert pour ainsi dire à
rien la présence de ces monstres ailés
dans des endroits aussi incongru et leur
rareté par ailleurs montrent que ces
grottes doivent être des zones de refuge
pour ces espèces issues d'un autre âge
deuxième singularité de ce vestiaire
c'est la diversité foisonnante
d'hominidés représenté en terre du
milieu
là où sur terre la seule espèce
d'hominidé encore vivante est homo
sapiens la terre du milieu compte une
dizaine d' espèce d'hominidé des elfes
poils aux fesses des hobbits coelho slip
des nains point commun des gobelins pas
l'aura des zapa le front des trolls pas
le niveau
à ce propos ces derniers dont les moeurs
majoritairement nocturnes ont fait
naître la légende urbaine qui se
transformer en pierre à le jour levé
ainsi que les autres géants sont
intéressants car elle présente les
caractéristiques les plus primitifs des
hominidés de la terre du milieu
il possède une intelligence qui quoique
pas négligeable reste somme toute assez
limité par rapport à la nôtre et en plus
leur bras sont plus longs que leurs
jambes
exactement comme c'est le cas chez les
chimpanzés ou les gorilles ces géants
représente donc l'équivalent en terre du
milieu de nos grands singes parmi eux
les n2 se distinguent par leur langage
complexe et leur incomparable sagesse
est ce à dire que les n 2 serait les
ancêtres des hommes sûrement pas les n2
sont bien trop dérivé pour être les
ancêtres des hommes leur morphologie
parfaitement adapté à la vie en forêt
n'aurait en aucun cas puis évolué pour
donner naissance à celle des hommes
à l'image des paresseux qui laisse
pousser sur leur pelage des algues
unicellulaires les end laisse pousser
sur des végétaux comme morceau qui leur
assure un camouflage parfait et les
callosités de leur peau imite
parfaitement celle d'un tronc d'arbre
limitation est si parfaite qu'en fait
les aides se considèrent eux-mêmes plus
comme des arbres comme des hommes leur
mythologie les fait d'ailleurs plus
volontiers décembre des arbres que des
primates du coup hunt et hommes
descendent tous deux d'âgés en
ancestrale bien qu'on ne sache pas
lequel faute de fossiles et si les actes
ne peuvent pas être des ancêtres directs
des hommes
il n'en reste pas moins que les
caractéristiques communes qu'il possède
comme l'intelligence montre qu'il
partage en ancêtre commun c'est ancêtre
commun pourrait-il être à 9
mais oui parce que si l'on en croit la
les gens sont les f qui les premiers ont
peuplé la terre du milieu d'abord ouais
enfin ça c'est ce que les elfes veulent
vous faire croire parce que la
mythologie naine est très clair sur ce
point ce sont des nains qui sont arrivés
les premiers
alors retourne dans ta forêt bouffeurs
de salars et toi avant retourne que je
suis dans ton trou même plus à l'aise à
nos âges macasty c'est comme ça
évidemment c'est partout pareil pour
mieux légitimer sa domination et son
hégémonie sur les richesses de la terre
du milieu
chacun cherche à instrumentaliser la
science de ses origines à des femmes
politiques
ici les mains et un échange bon on peut
concéder aux elfes que s'ils ne sont pas
arrivés les premiers au redoux cas ce
sont les premiers à avoir développé une
civilisation et donc qu'ils possèdent la
plus ancienne des organisations
sociétale de la terre du milieu
en témoigne le fait qu'ils sont restés
primitivement des chasseurs cueilleurs
les civilisations très anciennes a donc
accumulé une grande masse de savoir par
l'expérience comme la médecine par les
plantes souvent prise pour de la magie
et fiq par les autres peuples de la
terre du milieu
ses nombreuses légendes ainsi que la
grande longévité des elfes et le fait qu
aux yeux de tous les autres peuples de
la terre du milieu
tous les elfes se ressemblent ont fait
naître le mythe de leur immortalité
ce dernier point de leur biologie est
encore fort discuter dans la communauté
scientifique car israël forment un
peuple très secret enfin les elfes
partage sûrement des liens de parenté
étroit avec les autres hominidés à
oreilles pointues
à commencer par le hobbit dont la petite
taille est une adaptation à la vie
souterraine mais aussi les orques et les
gobelins qui sont identiques aux f à
tout point de vue un parent qui sont
strictement carnivores ce régime
alimentaire bien particulier serait une
adaptation à la vie dans les terres
arides et dépourvu de végétation du
mordor et de la rade
il possède donc des crocs pointu ainsi
qu un intestin adapté à la direction de
la viande relativement plus courts et
donc moins volumineux que celui des
autres hominidés ce qui leur confère une
allure rachitique lacarne ivory
expliquerait aussi pourquoi ils sont
aussi mauvais a mais peut-être le pensez
vous que les orques et les gobelins
descendez directement des trolls mais
non il n'en possède aucune
caractéristique typique et non et
surtout il ne faut pas oublier non plus
concernant ce dernier point que ce que
l'on connaît des orques ne nous a été
rapporté que par leurs ennemis par
ailleurs l'hypothèse d'une origine
commune aux elfes et hauser qui est
soutenu par les récits légendaires qui
situe l'origine des arcs parmi les elfes
corrompu par le mal
les hominidés à police restant tels que
l'ena et les hommes sont difficiles à
classer les uns par rapport aux autres
car il ne partage aucune
caractéristiques morphologiques qui leur
soit propre
les noms comme les hobbits se sont
adaptés à la vie souterraine mais leurs
manies ce métal évident
différent de celui des hobbits les
premiers sont des noms d'alu rippert
adultes ou même les femmes ont des
attributs masculins alors que celle est
second au contraire même les adultes
ressemble à des enfants et on en oublie
encore plein d'autres dont on ne sait
presque rien comme les résidents des
terres immortel qu'on aime les valeurs
ou bien encore les dunes da mais de
toute façon toutes ces espèces sont
capables de se croiser entre elles à
l'image d'aragorn qui doit sa grande
longévité à la petite part de sang d'elf
qui coule dans ses veines
il ne s'agit donc pas réellement
d'espèces différentes mais deux sous
espèces d'hominidés système science est
terminé merci de l'avoir suivi pour en
savoir plus sur ce sujet n'hésitez pas à
jeter un coup d'oeil aux liens qui sont
dans la description
merci à tous